I don't have anything on my back you
never see it I want to I want to see it
you can't see it or you don't want to
tattoo you just don't know about that
that's in like that'll really hurt
what's up GQ it's your boy daddy fast
sex
aka sir lucious a left foot the L stamp
allowed Monica the ladies like they
couldn't lip gloss on my lapel and I'm
gonna give you my tattoo tour you'll
feel me think I was 17 got first tattoo
it's right here it's like a heart with
my name in the band says dawn I put them
real name and name a mama gave because
we were artists you had to go to monkey
man and get a tattoo and this was like
the tattoo artist for the stars he also
did this lion that was my second tattoo
that this lion you know we started was
always about kingship and the crown is
always there because that's what we wear
for chefs I had to go something big I
mean we're like 10th graders you know I
mean like I said in a song I wore a tank
top to show off my tattoos thought it
was too I mean I was wearing off like a
basketball jersey when I had this one
right here that's why the second one I
got here because I was like see that
[ __ ] doing push-ups every day so your
bangs and your forearm pop out cool [ __ ]
[Music]
when I go to the tattoos I was doing
them like on both arms kid I had dirty
south where we was from we were about
this was like you know definitely
southern pride this was done by mr.
cartoon once I started going to him it
was like I didn't want to get tattooed
by anybody else
I like cartoon style man cuz it's more
graffiti like like always it's letters
he's drawing freehand and just you know
like kind of like the smoke and all the
little bits that he puts inside
everything he also did these to Bob wire
handcuffs I mean you can't home there's
no change between because you can
constrained and it passed that straight
up killer Mike was with me when I got
these and he got some tattoos - by the
time so we're just passing the Hennessy
like uh
he's working on his arm then this arm so
it's kind of painful then I got these
the dungeon family everybody in the
dungeon family from Andre 3000 CeeLo
green the whole goody mob organized
Noize if you're in the dungeon founder
even future got everybody got some sort
of DF tattoo I got to get my ELF tough
stuff because I was trying to ride a
motorcycle and I felt like I roll rats
on the F real bad it was ugly I fell in
the ditch
[ __ ] was scraped up I got rid of the
motorcycle I never rode my motorcycle
since then this right here was my pit
bull tattoo right here so I'm real heavy
in the pit bulls and this was actually a
make of my dog my first pit bull Carlito
it was painful as hell I also have on my
neck my son's bamboo name written in
cursive I have all my kids name with me
then this is my daughter Jordan right
here with the fire there and then I had
my son cross name tattooed across my
chest right here with some cherubs my
kids did from seeing my tattoos they
started getting tattoos yeah my son now
seventeen we got to give consent for him
yeah I definitely was cool because it
was something that was it's not gonna be
a fad you know I mean there was a
scripture that he believed in and he
plays football so it was like something
for protection almost
I have fiber scripture isaiah 54:17
which means no weapon formed against me
shall prosper the show so I'm protected
facial tattoos because I do films it's
definitely in style it's the style and
TOS got to get a real job as you got to
get a real job you better be prepared to
do using something extravagant for the
rest of your life it gonna be a mop in
the bucket somewhere in your future
cause ain't nobody complex you work at a
front desk